hello guys my name is Jono and welcome
to episode 114 of game programming yes
has been very long time since the last
episode so let's just get into this so
last time we did some pretty awesome
rotation with our projectiles and
whatnot and the edges implementing spray
rotation basically as well as fairly
efficient sprite rotation so I asked you
guys what you wanted to do and there was
a lot of mixed responses so what I've
decided to do is UI so we have
absolutely no UI right now I mean we've
got some basic do we even have we've got
like font rendering yeah I remember we
put that in but um we don't have any
kind of like you know if you look at
Rumble the mad god for example in fact
I'm just going to Google this right now
because rolling the mad God is kind of
what we're trying to recreate here so if
we Google roll in the backyard and we go
to images and we take a look at the
screenshot you can see it's got this
whole UI panel off to off to the right
yeah
which has you know a mini-map and what
happened in an inventory your players
stats all of that kind of stuff so we
want to kind of recreate this that's
what we're going to focus on on there on
the next like I don't know probably 10
or so episodes because it'll include
stuff like the mini-map
so to do that we need to set up some
kind of UI so that's what we're going to
do today so inside graphics I'm going to
just start off by making a new folder
whoops a new folder called UI and inside
UI I'm going to make a new class called
something like UI manager or something I
don't know we're just going to kind of
go with the flow here so if we look at
our screen which is our main renderer
not that one clearly you can just you
can just go away so if we look at our
main screen we've got a few fairly
capable things that we can do here we
can draw rectangles we can you know I
mean we probably won't do that too much
because it just creates price and draw
them but we can draw sprites we can
render text character waters that do I
don't know
written text character that's
interesting it's been a while since I
looked at this code so I'm going to have
to
just investigate okay so in render fonts
and that renders the text character okay
that makes sense so that's cool why
we've got a few different fairly capable
things that we can do here so we
definitely need access to a screen but
we also want some way to be able to call
this from player so when I'm programming
usually and I decide to implement some
new system and for some reason I haven't
really thought it through or whatever
what I usually do is I I start off with
its usage so if we go into player this
is a great example of this right I want
to be able to say in the player I want
to be able to render some kind of you
know you know like some kind of UI
element or something so I need access to
that okay so if we think about this and
we think about that romatic I picture
which I think is still like somewhere
yeah here it is so if we think about
this we also have to decide what we want
to actually render these things right
clearly they should be probably updated
by the player because if like all these
stats in in the mini-map all that's like
the health and whatnot that's all
relative to the player okay so we
definitely that data to be basically
populated by the player but should the
player be rendering UI that's a
different story
okay and do we even want some kind of UI
manager that's that's that's one other
way to look at it right because we can
really do this however we want so it's
sometimes it's a little bit difficult to
actually decide but what we'll do is
we'll probably because see what we could
do right is we could get something like
the level to render the UI for example
especially because the level will
control the mini-map and one on and in
the render you know when we render our
player so do we have a player like do we
I think we just render them along with
all the entities so in render we could
just say at the very end because we want
to render last render UI and that will
probably make more sense right so we
want to kind of do something like that
but we also want to be able to have the
player set all the data for the UI which
is where the which is where everything
kind of becomes a bit more complicated
so that's
go to the drawing board literally and
and see what we can come up with so
let's see okay so right now our setup is
pretty simple we've got our game class I
think it's just called rain or something
now that's called game cool we've got
our game class and then we've got and
then what game does is it renders level
right and then level goes through all of
the entities including the player and
draws that okay so at game level we
probably want to say you know what
apartment rolling level which is like
all of our actual game right we also
want to probably draw the UI okay and
the UI might include something again
like a um like a mini-map or something
but that's alright because the level
might be able to render the mini-map so
we kind of want you I to be a static
kind of thing because there is only
going to be one UI there's not going to
be you can only have multiple you is
right there's one UI layer so to speak
so that being said we definitely want
game to render UI but we also want
player to write to UI and entity
probably to write to you I just
everything to be able to write the right
to the right to the UI so particularly
probably level wants to have UI as well
as game so we could set it we could set
it up le simply like it doesn't need to
be static or something and we might have
a go doing that right now but um
essentially what we want is pretty
simple so again what I'm doing right now
is I'm planning this stuff out in front
of you guys but I'm also not actually
writing you I'm Angie yet I'm actually
just figuring out how I want to use UI
manager first because that's going to
make it so much easier to write so what
I want to do is I want to have a UI
manager in the game I'll just call this
UI whoops
UI manager okay I want to have this in
the game I want to probably instantiate
it somewhere here
okay and I might have to pass some
things and we don't know yet
and then I offer C I probably want to
update it and I also want to render it
probably so let us see where we render
our level probably after the level right
okay and that's a fairly basic concept I
also want to give the level a UI manager
so I could do that what we growl level
okay we just set it to spawn here so
that's a bit different cause it's static
yeah we do something like that
one thing I would probably say will
probably be a bit better is if we made
it static and we had something over here
like public uy manager yet UI manager
and that would be static as well so by
doing it this way we kind of avoid the
whole passing around a bit and the thing
is it's totally acceptable and fine and
probably ideal actually to do it this
way because we know that there's only
going to be one one ui manager there's
not that it's in the UI manager is
literally the manager for the UI so if
we have multiple UIs
we'll just have all them inside this
class but this class there's just one
off so that's a bit important so now of
course we have the ability to be like oh
do you want the player to write stats to
it no no problem let's make a UI manager
here I'll just call it UI here and we'll
import it and then when we when we mock
up when we make our player I can just go
ahead and say UI equals UI sorry game
dot care to Y manager and that's it it's
done and now I've got access to that in
this class fine and I can just keep
calling this by the way but it makes
more sense to do it like this so in Java
I'm pretty sure this will just assign it
as a reference so it's not going to copy
it I think I don't know it's been a
while since I don't need Java code but
hopefully that's the case and if it's
not we'll have to just keep calling this
oh it'll be a bit annoying but I'm
pretty sure this is how it works alright
so that being said one thing we
to make sure that is because references
currently work in Java very well since
Java doesn't have the concept of
pointers or whatever is just all
implicitly chosen for you we have to
make sure we create the player after we
grab the UI manager so let's put the UI
manager like just straight away after
the screen for example to avoid any any
failures so UI manager right what does
it have we know it well it's probably
gonna have a constructor so let's just
write a constructor but it's also going
to have our update method and it's going
to definitely have our render method so
render is going to draw everything now
obviously render needs a screen
we know that screen is our renderer so
anything we want to draw such as thing
we just draw a rectangle this should
still work so let's just try 50 50 200
200 fixed so fixed it's going to be
false yeah this does what I remember so
physically false and we'll just raw it
in pink right now I think we're on 24
bits so that should work so if we go
back to game and render and pass in
screen as we do we pass that in
everywhere obviously that's our renderer
and yeah so if I launch this right now
it should just work so you can see that
we're drawing a rectangle now it's very
big because because I forgot that we are
in extremely low resolution let's go to
render make that something like 2020
launch it and here we have our basic UI
right now and you can see it's totally
fixed so it colorful is a player in the
sense that it doesn't it's part of its
not only part of the map if it was fixed
than well different story okay cool so
that's one way we can kind of do this
and I didn't realize draw a rectangle
actually didn't feel it but I guess it
was cultural not feel but anyway that's
our basic UI so what we want to do
basically is we want to have a few
different things we want to have
probably a list of things in our UI
manager so usually will have our UI made
out of panels and components so panels
are just basically
panels are panels are like I don't know
the best way explain is probably just to
show you so if we go back to run with
mag your panels are basically like this
kind of grayish background thing so
panel holds multiple components but the
main thing like to realize again like I
imagine you guys saying why don't you
just make a panel component and you
could but panels be alike groups right
so panels will usually have components
inside them and those components would
be relative to the group which is the
panel so what I mean is you can see this
mini-map is in the top left corner
basically and maybe there's about two
big CIL's or five pixels of pattern okay
so what we would do is we would create
the panel and we would be like the panel
is at x equals I don't know 600 and then
a Y zero right and then we would say
inside the panel we have a mini-map at
five comma five okay so in other words
we have this relative to the panel
not to the entire screen so that's what
panels are in in a sense they're groups
and everything we put inside panels
which are all of our UI components will
be relative to the panel not to the rest
of the game so that's really important
because it makes it much much easier so
we've got a list of panels right I'll
just call this panels I will make it a
new array list and we can have as many
of these as we like we'll probably
really only have one or two I don't
imagine us having are too many and then
we also want to have components because
the UI manager can have components
without panels actually no what we won't
do that will say well we'll update my
mind we'll say we have to have at least
one panel and that'll have the
components so you could have like an
invisible panel potentially okay so
we're making our UI panel we'll make it
inside uy of course we'll hit finish so
again this will have this will have oops
this will have a bunch of UI components
and we'll make that class as well and
then you y-components of course will
have things like updates so it's almost
like we're regretting our entity system
before you I think of it that way except
we don't have to worry about stuff like
artificial intelligence from our UI
obviously so that makes it a bit
different so you why components so let's
think of it this way do we have any kind
of vector
glasses we did now we do not wait we
definitely have vector 2i so let's make
the private vector - I will call this
position this is like kind of our thing
the thing is in Java continually making
vector two eyes is probably not not the
best for for performance because it
actually at dynamically our heads them
on them on the heap so not the best but
it's a right will where we shouldn't we
shouldn't be creating these multiple
times per frame or anything so it should
be fine
the other thing we'll do is we'll have
okay so we need a lot of things right
we'll probably have something like a
string or a lot of string which is a
labels when the component might have a
label we could have a lot of things in
here we might you know what I might do
is I might actually break this down into
several components so for now we'll just
have a position we'll have a color
so we'll have a background color well
might we might have a foreground color
or whatever we weren't weren't deal too
much with that but I'll set the position
all to position here will set will have
a
we'll have a we'll make this public iPad
will make most of the stuff of it before
you guys start screaming about getters
and setters it's extremely unwise to
have both a getter and a setter
especially they do nothing except just
return and set values because that just
basically adds inefficiency to your
program I don't know why people do that
people will have like both a getter and
a setter for something like position
it's like if you got both a getter and a
setter just make the field public it's
no different except you're it's better
for performance because you know
continually calling methods so yeah
anyway that aside so what we'll do is we
will probably have things like I don't
know what I'm going to make this more of
a base class so UI component is just one
thing we have we might have something
like a UI label for example factor we'll
do that right now
we'll make a UI label which extends UI
component and then a label is exactly
what it sounds like it's just a bunch of
text so that's a constructor yeah we'll
make the label of whatever position we
want exhibit force this will have stuff
like make public as well public string
text okay so when it comes down to
rendering let's say UI component we'll
have random make sure that this is Texan
screen of course same with panel so
we'll just pretty much everything will
have these things then it will put in
here yet but keep it around okay so this
label and then we'll probably override
the render method here and make it
render our thing so we'll probably have
a font as well private font font yes and
we can probably our fonts pretty big
right now isn't it probably need to
reduce it but let's for now just set it
equal to a new font I think we just do
that right I don't remember how this
works yes a font to Arial to PNG okay
okay looks pretty good so what we'll do
is we'll
yeah so I guess we'll just go farm to
render X Y so position to x position Y
and then text will be text and a screen
will be spring cool so why is this
complaining how is that not what hang on
the mares when did I make this hmm okay
that's fine so we'll we'll make this
public the reason I had a getter and
setter here by the way is a different
story
I had a setter that returned vector 2i
which is different because then you can
just stack your sets for example well
we'll definitely make that public okay
so position dot X and positioned a white
X screen fantastic so there's our format
during going on now as far as update
goes and whatnot this is really
important what needs to happen is
remember everything needs to be relative
to the panel so we've got we'll have a
vector 2i position here as well so UI
panel is basically a component as well
I've made it a component though but I I
might have I probably should have okay
so this stop position equals position so
one needs to happen is we'll do this in
the update because it doesn't really
matter too much but we'll go for it in I
equals zero we'll go through all of our
we just use a 4h lupillo if we will go
through all of our components panels or
sorry all about panels this is different
we have to go through all that panels um
we don't actually have to do this I
thought we were in UI I've we are in UI
panel yes my bad which is called this
panels should be call components little
we were in UI manager so for all of our
arm components we need to go ahead and
set our we have to go component dot
position
it's probably going to be more like an
offset actually we'll set the offset to
our position basically so in UI
component we'll have offset make sure we
instantiate this and then we'll have a
public void so that we can just make
this if we make this default visibility
means only this package will be able to
access it well and this as well as like
private but also the package so this
will prevent something I'll show you get
them in it's a cool trick that isn't
used a lot but probably true probably
should be okay so if we make this
default so it has no visibility modifier
we can go out into your eye panel you
can see this is still valid it's like
that offset yeah I know what that is but
then if we try and do it from like say
game and we're like we're actually how
few eye panels in game but if we did
have a UI panel so if we did have a UI
panel what that quickly yeah and we did
try to do something like panel dot you
can see set offset isn't isn't a thing
it says that it's under flight well
actually it probably is undefined I'll
probably main component I did mean
component my bad so they do component
you can see set offset is not visible
but it is to think so that's a quick
little trick so yeah so we can do some
like that
anyway it's ah offset will probably move
this down here as well okay cool
so there we go we've got our off side
being our offset being set which means
that when we actually go ahead and
render it we need to basically change
our position based on that
so in you I label we have to go position
X plus offset dot X okay the ad test got
our screen everything was good so now
let's see this in action so now you eye
manager we have to copy our UI panels
for loop and just do it for UI panel
panel panels and panel a lot of stuff
here
we don't set offsets or anything
actually we don't need this at all what
I meant to do was this so panel dot
render screen and of course therefore
updating application updation should be
a word there we go cool fantastic done
so now we should be able to draw things
UI component you have panels of panels
for example let's go ahead and say
something like this let's let's just fit
it for the purposes of this will have
lab sprite which will just set equal to
new sprites so how do we create a new
sprite based on size and color okay with
high color so hmm I don't know let's
just say we have a width of say I don't
know how big fingers are in this game
100 and 300 that might be able to screen
or whatever but we'll see position will
set yeah whatever and of course Rena
needs to happen so render apart from
okay we obviously need to component
update
and component render okay so we
obviously need to whoops we obviously
need to actually run at the panel itself
so for now we'll just imagine it's a
sprite or whatever and we'll just say
screen dot draw or what is it renders
right so x position Y position is just
positioned or X and position or Y spread
a sprite fixed will always be false
okay fantastic so there we go done and
then then that will obviously go through
all of our UI components and render them
and that does nothing because everything
is in UI label it seems okay fantastic
so let's try this out now first of all
we need to have a few nice methods here
such as add add panel so we'll add a
panel let's say panel stop and panel
will have a similar thing in a uy
manager sorry in UI panel which adds
components so add component you like
opponent can Honan
okay and we'll go components but add
component oh so much component okay so
we've got that that's good
so back in Slayer now I let's just run
and make sure I've we're all good in the
hood
and we are all good in the hood so what
we'll do is we've got our UI editor here
so let's just try something like uy dot
and panel and we'll have a UI panel so
let's stick this like let's take this at
maybe for now fifty-fifty now we'll 52
zero there's a bit like weird in fact
we'll put will pop it at zero zero for
now so some left corner so the dry one
will figure out the right one in a
minute so we'll add the panel and then
also to the panel will add a new UI
component sorry we're going to New York
without a new UI label and the position
will be yeah we'll keep it like zero
zero and the text I think by default is
just nothing so Ruy label should
probably have text right so back in
whoops back and player I will add in
hello all right cool
so now let's just see what happens all
right looks like absolutely nothing
happened
that's great where is our you my manager
being updated so if we go back to game
you a major update UI major render so
let's set a breakpoint and investigate
no okay so what are the controls in
Eclipse again f6f-5 will go five good
our panels are non-existent interesting
why do we have no panels does this get
called this
interesting because it should know it
doesn't okay
odd I might be wrong
wait no that's possible what I meant was
um how how does what doesn't play I do
that though ah we might have done the
non constructor we did two in the North
Roger let's do it in a right constructor
alright so take two let's get rid of
this point and other break point in game
cop get two constructors there we go so
now we've got a bit of a UI going on you
can see Hello is relative to that other
thing so it's it's the color is annoying
me why is it drawing in that car did we
tell her to draw in that color doesn't
really tell her to draw in that color
cuz that's weird in fact what I I don't
even remember specifying color I didn't
specify color oh if there's white aside
100 and the color of Drew was 300
fantastic let's make some kind of like
fairly bright kind of gray maybe like
that like a car there we go fantastic
so if we draw this we've got a bit of a
gray going on and looks like the panel
is probably a bit wide font spacing
between holes terrible as well but
that's okay let's set this to about 80
and maybe so 300 isn't actually enough
so let me just work this out properly
okay so our resolution is 300 by one
success that's what we care about right
it just because it doesn't look like it
ah yeah it probably is one six eight is
our height right so if we go back into
UI can you eye panel for example we
should be able to just share just like
something like 116 it should be just not
reaching okay good it is so we'll make
it one six eight so it fills up the
whole screen but what we'll also do is
we'll set up to 300 minus eighty so that
all my bad
I meant Wilkie there's a day dat seems
to be nice but what we'll do is we'll
set the position of the panel which is
set by player it seems
to be a 300 - 80 basically so that'll
make it on the left side alright on the
right side of the screen
kind of like in realm so there we go
cool so we add our view kind of feels
bad now I've probably send it right here
now and I should probably just reduce
the rendering size so it's not rendering
over there but it looks pretty good so
let's in fact Eddie might even be a bit
too much but we'll leave it at 80 for
now ok label wise a few things I want to
do first of all I think it's a way to
render this one of the different font
render options we've got
so there's spacing spacing color
okay so spacings first so minus 20
that's probably a lot color yeah we'll
keep it black okay well it's not a ring
at all now if I don't think it was
before anyway but where are we drawing
it that is the question
so players drawing it at Oh 0 0 well I
should be working but it's not
interesting
so where does it think it's drawing it
that is the question
let's launch this nope
all right let's step into that so x and
y are 0 & 1 0 that's wrong because the
offset should be not 0 so let's just
continue just no calm down
offset seems to be 0 no X is 200 though
okay I was just the first frame I guess
yeah
220 which should be fine ah here it is
it is being drawn all it was it was
right over there wait are we running it
was it was there it's gone now what okay
minus 20 might be a bit extreme let's
take it down to zero and see if this
still works okay it doesn't really okay
this is interesting
let's try and draw it it oh that's
because I'm
apparently not very smart made that why
obviously there we go
great so let's make this ah - 10-20 was
very insane
hotel of -10 let's make it - 5 we need
to make a different font but there we go
um so - for there we go looks pretty
good good so we've got that now let's go
into our player and change okay so it's
a zero zero that doesn't know clear it
heard me
okay fine - like two one
okay maybe not that small - ten yeah
there we go so that was kind of nice
right we've got hollow here and we're
throwing some brilliant UI and
everything seems to be working pretty
good okay cool any questions leave them
down in the comments below next episode
we'll continue on with this UI and make
it a lot better will maybe start with
displaying some player stats and whatnot
and Avenger will get to the mini-map so
if you guys enjoyed this episode please
hit like button it will help me make
more and I'll see you guys next time
good bye
you